[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Welcome to this
episode of "Click to Deploy,"
a series where we
show you how easy it
is to deploy solutions from
the Google Cloud Marketplace.
In this episode,
I'll show you how
to set up an Apache
Cassandra database
deployment through
Google Cloud Marketplace.
Cassandra is an
open source NoSQL
distributed database
that is typically
used for training and inference
of deep neural networks.
We'll start by
searching for Cassandra
in the GCP Marketplace.
For the purpose
of this tutorial,
let's choose the Google
Click to Deploy a Cassandra
virtual machine.
We are sent to this
landing page, which
shows us some very important
information about Cassandra,
like an overview of
what Cassandra is,
details about the
virtual machine
and its operating system,
and most importantly,
the estimated monthly cost
of choosing this solution.
Let's click the Launch button
to start this deployment.
Now we get to choose some
important specifications
for our deployment.
We'll start by naming our
deployment for this video.
We will name it cass-101.
Next, we'll choose the zone.
For this tutorial, I'll
keep the default zone.
Then we can decide
on the cluster name.
I'll choose the
default, Test Cluster.
Next, we can determine
the instance count.
I'll keep the count as the
default count of three.
Next, we will
choose Machine type.
For this video, I'll
use e2-highmem-4,
which are cost-optimized VMs.
Finally, you can also decide
on other specifications
like network
interface, firewall,
and enable Stackdriver
logging and monitoring.
Now that we've completed
the specifications,
we'll click the Deploy button.
Great.
So now our Cassandra
VM is deployed.
And now, we see the
Deployment Manager.
The Deployment Manager allows
you to create and manage
cloud resources.
Here, we see the deployed
Cassandra instance,
which includes files that
show VM instance, disk,
and firewall information.
Now, we can test out
this Cassandra instance
by running a couple commands.
There you have it-- a
Cassandra instance created
with a click of a button.
If you enjoyed this video,
please subscribe and hit
the Like button.
If you'd like to deploy
your own Cassandra
virtual machine
on your own, make
sure to click the
link down below.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]